A Day of Reckoning for Alec Baldwin
Judge Jeanine interviewing the
prosecutors bringing charges against the
actor and the rust film armorer they are
set to face two counts of involuntary
manslaughter in the tragic death of
cinematographer Helena Hutchins one of
the charges could put Baldwin behind
bars for a minimum of five years and it
looks like this interview Alec Baldwin
did is coming back to haunt him
I didn't pull the trigger so you never
pulled the trigger no no no no no I
would never point a gun that I'm going
to pull a trigger at them never
the Santa Fe County district attorney
and special prosecutor telling Judge
Jeanine that Baldwin isn't being
truthful and they say Hutchins would be
alive if he had done his job
we definitely believe he pulled the
trigger
um the FBI lab report confirms that so
definitely the trigger was pulled all
right so his statement is not correct
under any circumstance
we don't believe it is Mr Baldwin had a
duty at the base level to never hold a
gun and point it at a person while
pulling the trigger but he also had a
duty as an actor and a producer on that
set to have the bullets checked or to
check them himself to make sure that
they weren't live We Believe Baldwin as
a producer knows everything that goes on
on this set and so that yeah there was a
lot of problems there was a lot of there
are a couple accidental discharges there
was a lot of safety concerns that were
brought to the attention of management
and and he did nothing about it so there
were just this was a loose and Reckless
scene where safety was compromised just
to save money the decision to charge
Baldwin certainly not easy given who he
is and the media circus around the case
did you feel any pressure to go one way
or the other
you know we we looked at this case for a
long time and and sure there's a lot of
media attention and Al Baldwin's an
A-list actor but again we were just
looking at the facts of the case and
again Alec Baldwin he is an A-list actor
and and there's a lot of you know hype
around all that but he isn't above the
law you know we don't feel public
pressure we we're prosecutors uh we're
we're doing the right thing and what the
the facts support and we believe it
supports involuntary manslaughter and
here's another interesting part of Judge
jeanine's interview when she asked if
Baldwin was willing to work with
investigators
did Baldwin cooperate
yes he cooperated in that he did
willingly turn over his phone after some
negotiations with his lawyers
and let's get judge jeanine's reaction
after we see this one more little bit
about whether he would take a plea watch
here
will you engage in plea negotiations
with Baldwin
I can't comment on that at this point it
would be unethical for a prosecutor to
talk about that all right judge
congratulations on getting an exclusive
interview really powerful very timely
what was your main takeaway well my main
takeaway was that the prosecutor uh Mary
uh Carmack alt-wise is a very straight
shooter to sorry use that punt but she
is someone who's very focused on the law
focused on the facts she knew that she
was coming up against the case that it
will be worldwide that is really
something where it's almost as though
the burden of proof will be increased
with a jury in a case like this we've
seen what happens with celebrities she's
not letting that bother her it's very
clear to her that it was a set where
safety was compromised they didn't take
into account the safety of the
individuals they had notice of it he had
notice of it the armorer who's also
charged with involuntary manslaughter
she herself had discharged live rounds
so everyone knew that this was a
dangerous situation and and the truth is
that that Baldwin lied when he said I
would never point a gun and pull the
trigger that's a lie based on the type
of gun it's a single action you have to
pull that trigger and so the forensic
evidence along with an and I don't know
if there's any video of his actually
shooting Elena Hutchins plus they now
have the third defendant who's a guy by
the name of Dave Halls who was a second
armorer who has agreed to testify he's
pled guilty to the unlawful use of a of
a weapon and he will testify against
Baldwin and Hannah Gutierrez read now
she was a very inexperienced armorer she
never should have been on the set they
did it for money and Alive was life was
lost as a result of it and she had
repeated notice it was a problem now I
also want to make one point I've watched
a couple of interviews everybody's
saying we don't know where that live
round came from you know what is it
relevant Maybe us maybe no it depends on
the jury what's relevant is what Alec
Baldwin did and how he handled the gun
handle the gun on a set where they knew
there were problems in live rounds and
where he used that gun and pulled the
trigger at a human being in the prime of
her life the mother of a son who is now
dead because of his actions I have one
question about that um when that when he
did the interview with George
Stephanopoulos and said I never pulled
the trigger it was interesting because
in he did interviews initially after she
died and she he never said at that time
I never pulled the trigger I imagine
that if that had been true he would have
said that initially like I don't know
what happened I didn't even touch it
yeah but you know I think what happens
in these cases is you know everybody has
a group around them of friends so people
who think they know how to handle it
what to say or defense attorneys who are
saying you know you can use this as an
excuse and people listen to it keep your
mouth shut and believe me the more you
say the better for me when I used to be
a prosecutor but um if if you're gonna
lie it's not going to help you out under
any situation take it around the table
comment or question or comment yeah I
think it really is important to find out
how that live round got there that's the
biggest question because what if it was
deliberate right he didn't you have to
understand as bad as this was there was
no intent to kill this woman he didn't
say I'm gonna charge I know but my point
being is they need to find out how that
bullet got in there because what if that
was it that was intentional the bullet
was put in there intentionally but it is
his intervening action that created the
death what did he do was it he picked up
a gun that he thought had a blank in it
yeah I don't care what you think anyone
who's got a gun Greg who is taking a gun
right on a set where he is charged
remember as an actor and a producer
right a man who knows it's not safe for
him not to look at that gun and decide
for himself whether it's safe that would
be like you saying to me here Jim and
here's a gun and there's no problem with
it it's cold and I go out on the Avenue
of the Americas I pointed at someone and
pulled the trigger and say he told me it
was a it was a cold gun but the truth is
at all like this no no yes it is once
you handle a gun it's your obligation to
follow the rules of safety that's why we
have gun training so he even though he
assumes that it's he could be tried for
manslaughter if somebody deliberately
put a live round in his gun it's a
voluntary manslaughter because he pulled
the trigger and pointed the gun okay and
he was responsible for what was going on
the set and he had Advanced I agree I
agree I think there is a large chance he
ends up in prison over this but he's got
eight kids you know what
what do you mean so what I was gonna I
was going to say that maybe it's a
relief to be in a minimum security
prison judge when you have eight kids
back off okay this is proof that we live
in a video game a hardcore leftist who
has condemned Republicans the NRA saying
that the NRA has blood on their hands
every time there's a mass shooting ends
up with blood on his hands after killing
a young woman with a handgun and again
not intentionally but it's careless and
careless matters and with that goes back
to the thing that I said at the
beginning when this happened it was such
a stupid decision to hire this woman
whether it's nepotistic because of her
dad or because she was edgy she you know
she was hyphenated she had tattoos she's
cheap but it was a stupid path because
NRA instructors are ready and they're
able to assist but they've demonized the
NRA so much they don't do that and that
if you had somebody there on the set you
would have probably prevented this from
happening but she know you know they
think that they thought oh this is great
this is so interesting I often I also
wonder what would have happened if this
was an outspoken conservative and not an
outspoken liberal celebrity there would
be no kid gloves there'd be no empathy
for the other side on this show we
actually Express empathy not just for
the family for the victim but we know
that his life this is the worst
experience of his life he I mean he
actually killed a person so it was like
but they would not afford US the same
luxury if it was one of us
Jessie yeah Jessica you're fine I don't
think Alec Baldwin I don't think Alec
Baldwin can go to trial if they let him
cut a play I would cut that play in a
heartbeat he is probably dumb enough to
take the stand in his own defense and
would get rocked on Cross this thing
could be televised it could wreck his
entire career he's looking at five years
if he gets convicted and he's got a lot
of kids and he's got a lot of bills he
needs to go back to acting because once
you're before the trial or during the
trial or after sensing your earning
power is shot and he already unloaded
all the less pricey real estate to
settle the case civilly so
if I was his lawyer I would say let's
settle if they let us settle but his
lawyer this guy's name is Luke Nicholas
he got named to like
40 under 40 hot lawyer list he's young
he's hungry he's super talented wants to
make a name for himself but he's an art
litigator like he looks after stolen Van
Gogh's and forgeries so I this is a case
he's never had to handle before I'm a
little bit worried about that I think
the honorable move is to take a plea if
they give it to you and get on with your
life and say you're sorry and that's it
but I respect this D.A I last year said
this D.A was not going to indict I
didn't think she had it in her and she
has it in her and she treated this guy
Baldwin like a Joe Schmo and I have a
lot of respect for that I think if it
does go to trial she'll get a conviction
by the way the maximum sentence is six
and a half six and a half it's a long so
you add the involuntary manslaughter to
the gun charge long time wow all right
Jessica
um I agree with everything that's been
said I too was wondering about how the
live round got there just because it's
an interesting point about the set right
the set where union workers were walking
off right saying that it's too unsafe
here I think two separate Crews had done
that I think it's really interesting
that Baldwin declined to have the gun
checked by this armor who wasn't
experienced it was only our second job
but he took the word of the ad second in
command armor this David Halls to say
it's a cold gun no problem that's on him
I wonder also I mean actors are so
hungry for producer titles right this is
one of the things in negotiations with
their contract that they want their name
I wonder if that's going to change from
this if you want this kind of liability
as well on top of it
um and I was struck by I was listening
to a gun safety expert talk about this
and he said just because it was an
accident doesn't mean it isn't a crime
yeah and it's something we don't talk
about we see guns in movies constantly
and I think that people just get so
casual about it that these accidents can
happen and I know that it has been a
long time since something like this did
but I wonder how people who are planning
out the next film are feeling about this
right now in terms of how seriously
people are taking it judge incredible
interview yeah congratulations where
else will you be tonight be on prime
time I'm on prime time okay then I'm on
Hannity all right okay that's what I
mean you get a big interview you've got
to keep working and I gotta keep working
on it there's much more from judges sit
down interview with Alec Baldwin
prosecutors you can watch the full
interview right now at foxnews.com hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now